there's no doubt that the restrictions
we have put in place
and that people are abiding by have
dramatically slowed the spread of the
virus
but of course that figure for hospital
admissions more than 500 in a week is
still too high
the number of new cases we are seeing
more than one thousand a day on average
is also still
too high and this is crucial while we
have seen a leveling off
we are not yet seeing a sustained fall
in cases in fact although there was a
very slight fall in some recent
weeks last week we actually saw a slight
increase
clearly that requires continued caution
as i've set out before a rising or even
plateauing rate of infection
is not a stable position we want to see
a decline
in cases so we'll be monitoring the
situation carefully in the days ahead
and we
can't rule out the need to take action
beyond what i will set out today
also in light of the situation i've just
outlined it would clearly not be prudent
to ease restrictions today
with one exception for our three island
authorities which i'll set out shortly
however i can confirm that no local
authority will
move down a level this week in light
of particularly sharp increases in cases
uh unfortunately three local authorities
will move up
from level two to level three and while
no local authority i'm pleased to say
will move to level four this week there
are a number that are giving us some
cause for concern
and we'll be monitoring these
particularly closely over the next few
days
let me turn now to those areas currently
in level two
i can confirm that aberdeenshire
aberdeen city the borders
dumfries and galloway and argyle and
butte will all remain
at level two these are all areas that
will be hopeful
as i am of a move to level one soon
however while there are some signs of
stability and even improvement in most
of them
there is not yet sufficient evidence of
a sustained decline in the number of
cases
indeed i have to point out that in the
borders and although to a lesser extent
in dumfries and galloway
we have seen an increase in cases in the
most recent data that we have available
for these reasons we consider it
sensible for these areas to remain
in level two for now but we do remain
hopeful that some or all of them
will be able to move to level one soon
the other areas currently in level two
are fife
perthink and ross and angus and i can
confirm that we have taken
the very difficult but in our view
necessary and precautionary decision
to move fife person controls and angus
to level three
from friday while on the raw indicators
alone
angus and perthink and ross are not yet
meeting the level three thresholds and
fife is meeting
just one of them all three areas are on
a sharply rising trajectory
the most recent data shows that in the
space of a week the seven day number of
cases per hundred thousand of the
population
has increased in perth and can roth by
32 percent
in fife by 40 percent and in angus by 47
the advice of the chief medical officer
and national clinical director
is that level 2 restrictions may well
not be sufficient to slow down
and reverse increases of this magnitude
and as a result an early move
to level three was strongly recommended
i know
how disappointing this will be to
residents and businesses in these three
areas
however and this is an important point
by acting now
we can hopefully prevent an even more
serious deterioration
in the situation in future i would ask
people living in these areas to check
the scottish government website to
understand the restrictions in place
at level three businesses will also find
details there of the financial support
available from the scottish government
which of course
is in addition to the uk government's
furlough scheme
now a factor relevant to both angus and
perth and
ross is proximity to and interaction
with
the city of dundee then they entered
level three on second november and i can
confirm that it will remain
at level three for now however i hope
the three authorities going into level
three this week will take
some encouragement from it the most
recent data shows cases and test
positivity
declining in the city of dundee and
while it's too soon to be sure that this
will be sustained
i want to stress that the trend is very
much positive
at this stage i can also confirm that
the other 18 local authorities currently
at level 3 will remain there for now
however it is important to note that
there is a varied picture
across the level three areas and a move
to level four for some in the near
future
cannot be ruled out for reasons that i
will outline
however firstly on the positive side
some of the current level three areas
are
like dundee showing encouraging signs
there is
some volatility in the most recent data
for some of these areas but i would
mention with varying degrees of
confidence east lothian
city of edinburgh click manager eastern
bartonshire
falkirk midlothian north ayrshire and
east asia obviously we will monitor all
of these areas carefully but we
hope that if people continue to abide by
all of the restrictions
we will continue to see improvement and
some of these areas
may be able to move out of level 3
relatively soon